こんにちは
しばらくこのままで喋ろうかなと思ってる
んですけど
撮りますね
今日は僕の工作の話を聞いてもらいます
僕は
皆さんも小さな頃から
好きなことってあると思うんですけど
僕が小さい頃から好きなのは
工作でしたで今でも小さい頃の記憶で一番
覚えているのが
学校から帰って
工作に熱中してこうなんか作ってて
気づいたらあ
真っ暗だ」っていうそういう記憶が一番
残っててそういうのはみんな
ちっちゃい頃あったと思うんですけど
僕はそれを
ずっとなんか覚えててそれで仕事をしよう
と思いました
それで選んだ仕事が大工の仕事です
大工さんになれば
お給料をもらえてそして
道具も手に入って
技術も覚えられるいやこんないい仕事ない
んじゃないかなと思って
たまたま就職できたところが
僕は京都の謝辞建築でなんか思ったより
大変ですごいびっくりしたの覚えてるん
ですけど
大工の修行に入って
一番
印象に残っている
ことがあってそれがこう宮大工の仕事って
いうのは大きな木を扱ってたくさんの人と
今の言葉でコラボレーションしながら
仕事をするんですけどその
仕事をする時に
この大きな木を扱うとやっぱり
プレッシャーがすごいんですよねで僕が1
回こう
若い頃に
塗料に言われた言葉で覚えているのがこの
大きな柱が僕の担当になって流れてきて
今写ってる
これはもう針ですけどこの大きな木を
加工するのにものすごいこちら側もすごい
エネルギーを持たないと取り組めないん
ですよなんでかっていうとやっぱり相手も
元々は生物なんですよねその
木に
すごい気持ちを込めてやらないと負けて
しまうっていうことやその木を大切に
扱おう
そういうことを
宮大工の修行自体に
学んだと思ってますでこの宮大工の時に
修行時代に
宮大工の仕事で出る端材や廃材を使って
やっぱり
工作しちゃうんですよね僕
でこうお
寺の
柱の余りでカッティング
ボードを作ったりとか
板の端材でお盆を作ったりとか
集めて椅子にしたりとかついつい
交錯してしまうようなそんな大生活を送っ
てました
で10年前に僕は北海道に
修行を終えて戻ってきたんですけどそこで
工作をする
工作を仕事にする拠点を探します
でそこで出会ったのがこの
築70年を超えた
農家の家なんですけど
あの大家さんが
無理じゃないっていうぐらい
ぐちゃぐちゃだったんですけど
僕にとってはこう宮大工の仕事で
江戸時代のお寺の修理とかしてたんで
別にそんなに古い感じはしてないんです
けど
家族や
特に僕の父なんかは
近所でもお化け屋敷って言われてたんで
絶対出るって言って
うちの中に入ってこなかったりしました
ただ僕がその
家は古いことやぐちゃぐちゃなことよりも
一番驚いたことが
大工が自分で自分のように直したら
誰もお金払ってくれなかったんですよ
そんな当たり前のことに
全然気づかなくて
びっくりしたんですよね本当に今までこう
普通に大工仕事をすると
僕らの仕事は日当だったりするんですけど
それが1ヶ月まとめて入ってくるそういう
仕事のやり方したんでなんか
普通に仕事してる感覚と一緒なんですけど
誰もお金払ってくれないそれに驚いていく
つか
考えたことがありまして
まずお金をかけられないので人を呼ばない
で家族で治すってこととあとはそこにある
ものやみんなが使ってないもの
余ったものを使って
材料先に集めてからそれが何に使えるかを
考えて直せばいいんじゃないかなと思って
僕はその今の言葉でリノベーションなん
でしょうけど
当時なんかそんな僕リノベーションとか
持ってなくてこれもずっと工作だと思って
たんですよね
でそんな中この家はもう家族総出でもう2
年かけてようやく住めるようになって
でもらえてないものがあるときは
まだもらわないで使ってたんですよ例えば
トイレもお風呂も
キッチンも
床板も窓も
何もあったかなともらった問題だけなん
ですけどそれで直したんでもらえない時は
あの使いつけれないですよねだからお風呂
がもらえなくて済んでから3ヶ月ぐらいお
風呂なかったんですけどそれは今でも
ずっと嫁さんに言われてますでそんな中
そのいろんなものをもらえるようになった
僕は
ある素材が気になっちゃったんですよね
みんな気づいてると思いますけどそれが
このシャケ箱です
シャケバコってみんな知ってますか
あのこれも作らせてもらいましたけど
この
荒巻鮭を入れる木箱が
当時はまだ北海道には普通に
積まれていて最近はだいぶ少なくなってき
たんですけど
荒牧ジャケっていうのは北国の
食文化の一つで塩漬けにした鮭を
入れて保存して食べる
文化ですよねそれを輸送するためだけの
木箱なんですよこれ
それなのにどうですかこれ
めっちゃかっこよくないですか
って言ってたんすけど誰もいいって言わ
なかったんですよ10年前は何でかわかん
ないですけど僕はずっと好きでこんな
こんなかっこいいのになんでだろうって
例えば嫁さんにいやこれかっこよくないっ
て一緒に取りに行こうって言って最初
近くの
魚屋さんにね取りに行ったんですけどいや
もう二度と行かないって言われて
そんなことしながらあの僕は
普通の仕事もしながらこの家を直して
工作としてこのシャケ箱にどんどん惹かれ
て
壁に貼ってみたりそしたら嫁さんにいや
それはやりすぎだからって言われたり
家具に家具の修理に使ったりしてなくない
とか言われながら
あのそれでもめげずにやってたんですけど
まあそんな僕に
仲間が現れました
あの彼が小山さんです今ここにはもちろん
いませんけどあの
彼が僕を僕のやってるこの酒箱のクラフト
僕の工作を一番最初に褒め称え一緒にやろ
うって言ってくれた
貴重な変人の人です
で彼は
友人を落として知り合った家具職人で
ちょうど独立したばっかりで僕がやって
いる古いリノベーションやその
建物のことを知りたい勉強したいから一緒
に仕事させてくださいって言って手伝いに
来てくれたそんな
同い年の
職人さんなんですけど
彼が僕のやってる仕事に見て一番最初に
言ったのが
村上さんこのシャケどこめっちゃかっこ
よくないですか」って言って何で使わない
んですかといや使ってるよ
ほらっていろ見せてそれで一番最初に作っ
たのがこの鞄
これもみんなに回したいぐらいなんすけど
かっこよくないですかこれ
ねさっき言ってもあんまりみんな運って
言ってくれる人少ないんですけど
で僕はこれを持っていろんなところにこう
仕事に行ったりとか例えばプレゼンに行っ
たりとか
打ち合わせに行くのにこれを持っていくと
例えば電車でこうやって乗ってると何です
かそれって言われたり
空港で声かけられたりそんなことしながら
小山さんと一緒になってものづくりをして
ましたでそこに
恵庭に同じくUターンで帰ってきた
ギター職人が来て
村上さんかっこいいですねと
僕もなんか作ってみたいですとじゃあこれ
鮭僕持ってけよで彼はウクレレを作ってき
たりとかそうやってこう
活動するメンバーが増えたり
賛同する人が増えてきてでそうなってくる
と今度僕が気になってきたのはこの車検が
こってこうやって楽しい楽しいって作って
ますけど
これ何でできてるんだろうと
全然知らなかったんですよ
でこれがどういう材料でどういうところで
作られているかそれが気になってきてまた
調べていったのが今映ってる
釧路の鮭箱工場です
でこの鮭箱工場に行ってまあ
彼は波多野さんというんですけど
社長さん
荒牧の父って言われてるんですけど
僕らの中でですけどねまだ荒巻でもない僕
たちをねこんなの持ってきてこんなのとか
作った椅子とか
持ってバーって行って
すいません
工場見してください」って言ってですごい
驚いてでもなんか感激してくださって
やっぱそれまでシャケ箱といえばこう積む
だけとかバラしてこう居酒屋の壁に貼る
だけだったのがこんなにもいろんな変化が
あるんだって驚いてくれて
で彼を通して
車検箱の原料になる
林業やってる
木材屋さんとか中に入れる鮭
を加工する水産加工会社なんかを
紹介してくれてやっぱりより僕らに
酒箱に対する
知識だったり印刷の機会今映ってるこれが
林天気なんですけど
その印刷のこととかいろんなことを教えて
くれたのが彼ですでそのうち今度
東京で展示しませんかって言われたんです
よね
で
工作ですよこれね
展示してもいいんですかって話ででその時
に初めて
当時は
ギター職人と
家具職人と
僕3人が作り手でなんかそれぞれかっこ
いいだろうかっこいいだろうってやってた
だけなんですけどそれがこう初めて展示に
なるどうするって言って値段もつけたこと
がないそれすらまた
ユニット名すらないそれでつけたのが
荒巻鮭の木箱だから
荒牧っていう名前にしてしかもローマ字に
したらかっこいいんじゃないかって言って
それで暫定的に決めたのが実は腹巻
プロジェクトなんですよそこで初めてと
いう言葉になって
それでこう展示をしてみたんですよねこの
時も東京で展示することに受かれすぎて
ですね何回も東京行き過ぎて
終わったら大赤字で
嫁さんに正座させられました
あの今もあんま変わってないですけど
やっぱり
好きでやってることなんで
で
展示をして
他のところでも展示してくださいとか
こんなの作りませんかとか
僕ら勝手にねアイディア出して
仕事もしてますよちゃんとあのやってる中
で今度は僕に来たのが
車検箱をデザインしてくださいって言われ
たんですよね
この会社札幌の
酒屋さんの箱なんですけど知ってる方も
いるかもしれませんけどこの会社の社長が
村上君さって
うち社長家庭令和の木箱を作りたいんだ
けど
村上君デザインできるって言われていや僕
デザイナーじゃないんだよって断ったん
ですけど
でもなんか考えたらなんか村上君たくさん
もう箱のこと知ってるでしょできそうじゃ
ないって言われて
じゃあということであの
荒牧プロジェクトに
グラフィックデザイナーも入ってもらい
叫ばこの歴史を紐解くところからやり
ながら
作ったのがこの木箱で今も実際に鮭が入っ
て
流通してます
でもっといいのがこの木箱が役目が終わる
と僕のところに来るっていう
究極の
最高ですね
今今はもう僕のところにいろんな酒場が
集まってくるようになってなんか村上さん
この鮭箱知ってますかっていうのが来たり
とかあとはシャケバコ積んであると僕に
写真撮って送ってくる人もいるんですよね
でそれは持ってるって言ったりとかで今
やってるのは僕この酒箱自体をやっぱり
世の中から消え行く北海道の文化になって
きてるって僕はそう思っててアーカイブ
する要は記録にしてこうやって取ってそう
することでデジタルで残ることでこんな
シャケバコがあったということは忘れる
ことはないし
復活させようと思ったら復活させられると
思って考えてます
美術館でも展示したりとかそうこれもね
これ
東京の美術館でやった時でなんかすげー
いい顔してたんですよね僕
これこそが工作だみたいな
顔してますよね
そういう活動を
工作として僕は
仕事もしてますよ何回も言いますけど
最近あの息子にシャケダイクって言われる
んだって
でこういうことをやってるうちになんか
頼まれてない工作だったのが
頼まれ始めたんですよ
そして本当に頼むのって僕は思うことも
あったんですけどこれ札幌パルコさんで
ショーウィンドウを
叫ばこれできませんかっていうご依頼を
受けてで僕本当ですかって言いました最初
多分あの
普段はマネキン入って服入ってるんだと
思うんすけど
多分鮭箱入った初めてですよね
きっと
これは東京であの
東京駅前のビルの中の居酒屋さんが
酒箱でやってほしいと
内装全部だと
本気ですかと
本気だったんですよだからそれに答える
べき僕あの
史上最大の荒牧プロジェクトと言ってるん
ですけど勝手に300箱ぐらいいろんな
ところに協力していただいて
送ってもらったり取りに行ったりして
掘りごたつ作ったりもう壁自体を
シャケバコにする
グラフィックとして天井にもシートこの
模様を使うそんなことをチームを作って
やります
最近ではその宮大工の仕事との
融合というかなんか
避けたい宮原大工だったみたいないろんな
最近なんか元宮大工って勝手に言われたり
するんですけど
別にやめてないんですよねまだなのでそれ
を知ってもらうためにもできるよっていう
のを見せたいと思って
酒箱で神社作ってみました
割とちゃんと作ったんですけど
あまりみんな見てくれないので今みんな見
てもらおうときました
で
酒箱のことやってたらはずなんですけど
なんか鮭の漁師さんと連絡取ったりとか
鮭の研究者の人の話聞いたりとかやっぱり
近年鮭が取れなくなってるのでその
鮭の
生体としての酒だったりその漁師さんが今
酒量をしながらどんなことを考えているん
だろうとか
そういうことに気になってきてで話を聞き
に行ってあそんな面白いこと考えたり
そんな面白い研究をされてるんだって思っ
て
ラウスでシャケサミットというイベント
やるんですけどそこでこう鮭の関係者を
集めてで料理人を呼んで
鮭の料理しか食べないそういう企画をやっ
たり
活動がなんかシャケ箱だったのがいろんな
広がりを見せてなんかいろんな人巻き込ま
れてくれてるんですよね
で今まで荒巻でいろんなことやってきたん
ですけど
なんかその活動の
一番の根っこはやっぱり
宮大工でやってきたいろんな人と組んでや
るってことです
最近はこうシャケバコでなんか僕もの作る
となんか
俺もできんじゃないかってこうマネされ
たりもするんですけど
僕はそれもいいと思ってて
でもその
誰かと一緒にやったことっていうのは
なかなか真似ができなかったりそこの場で
しか起こらないことでその人とのつながり
を作れるようになったのは
宮大工でのプロジェクト型の仕事をずっと
やってきたかなと思ってます
さらにやっぱり人と一緒に仕事をする上で
僕が一番大切にしていることは
自分のことを大切にすることだなと思って
て
僕はこの称賛の時のこれ僕なんですけど
称賛の僕
当時ともくんと言われたんですけど
称賛の友くんが喜ぶことをすることが一番
僕は自分にとって大切だと思ってます
自分を大切にできないと人は大切にでき
ないと思ってます
なので僕はその今こうして喋ってるこの声
や見ているものは
僕の中にいる
称賛のトモ君も見たり聞いたりしてると
思ってるんでそこにやっぱり嘘偽りがあっ
たりとか思ってないものを作っちゃったり
すると
悲しむと思うんですよねでその
僕の中にいる小さい科目の話せながらやっ
て続けてる工作が
それがこの荒牧のプロジェクトであり
僕の工作です
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]